dawa recette est encore dans nos
mémoires avec beaucoup de mystère qui
nous laisse sur notre faim
la famille de ré luke skywalker et j'en
passe et puisque vous me l'avez beaucoup
demander j'ai décidé de faire des
théories sur ce qui pourrait se passer
dans le prochain opus soit star wars 8
et voici donc trois théories que je vous
propose cette théorie est imaginée par
moi même mais me semble tellement
évidente
luke skywalker est devenu éminemment le
personnage plus puissant de la saga star
wars
c'est un personnage piliers de la saga
et on redécouvre vieux dans star wars 7
en solo son plus vieil ami est quant à
lui mort dans star wars 7 des mains de
son fils kaï lorraine il ne reste donc
plus que luke et leia
j'ai un peu du mal à expliquer cette
théorie pourtant elle met complètement
évidente dans ma tête
luc est un personnage recherché par tous
dans la galaxie
beaucoup veulent sa mort et d'autres non
personnellement je suis sûr à 100% que
l'udc va mourir pourquoi quittons un peu
l'univers star wars pour parler des
acteurs les premiers star wars avec l'uc
joué par mark hamill date des années
1977 à 1983
nous sommes plus de 33 ans plus tard les
acteurs ont beaucoup vieilli et nous
avons déjà eu la mort de ian solo joué
par harrison ford qui est aujourd'hui
âgé de 74 ans harrison a beaucoup
vieilli et on le voyait mal faire des
galipettes dans la nouvelle trilogie
star wars
le fait est que sa mort le fait sortir
de la série est donc arrêté star wars
les acteurs ne sont pas éternels et si
l'udc survie jusqu'à la fin de l'opus 9
cela sous-entendre a encore une suite
avec lui et jedi ce n'est pas de tout
repos
allez de 64 ans marc enfile de nouveau
le costume de jedi mais pour combien de
temps de plus les personnages en solo
les ja et l'udc ont déjà très bien vécu
et beaucoup pensent évidemment qu'il
faut une relève
nous avons l'exemple avec la première
trilogie obi-wan moeurs et même s'il
reste présent en tant que personnages
secondaires
il laisse la relève au nouveau
personnage de luke leia et ran
scénaristiquement parlant ce serait trop
à pitre historique luc vive jusqu'à la
fin de la saga sans problème même si
nous l'aimons tous il faut s'attendre à
une mort prochaine de ce personnage car
cela fait l'essence même de star wars
tous les grands jedi moeurs obi-wan yoda
mace windu couayron et j'en passe
d'ailleurs mark hamill à un peu fuite et
le fait que luke moore est certainement
dans les prochains opus
star wars 7 est un calque de star wars 4
je leur ai répété maintes et maintes
fois dans l'émission théorie mais en
même temps c'est vrai la mort de ian
solo est comparable à celle de obi wan
la destruction de la ba starkiller
l'étoile noire bref c'est un réel calque
le nom du prochain opus de star wars
serait the fall of the resistance soit
la chute de la résistance en français
cela ne vous évoque rien si on suit la
logique de la saga on peut associer cet
épisode à l'empiré contre attaque soit
star wars 5
dans cet opus les rebelles subiront pas
mal de problèmes et le titre de la chute
de la résistance correspond très
franchement à l'opus 5 donc star wars 8
serait un calque de star wars 5 comme
star wars 7 avec l'opus 4 maintenant
votre imagination peut s'amuser car si
on retranscrit plein de choses vont
arriver
tout d'abord la révélation de dark vador
qui est le père de luke
on pourrait alors supposer une
révélation sur les parents de ré ce qui
est fort probable reste tout de même le
personnage le plus rempli de mystère il
est très sincèrement possible que l'on
connaît son histoire dans le huit
ensuite l'apprentissage de la force de
l'udc avec le tout dernier jedi de la
galaxie yoda je dois vraiment vous faire
la comparaison
réapprendre à la force aux côtés de luc
le tout dernier jedi de l'épopée star
wars mais cela reste assez évident je
pense car ray vient de découvrir ses
pouvoirs et l'udc tentera de l'aider je
pense
le combat entre l'udc et dark vador
évidemment il y aura forcément de
nouveaux combats de sabre laser mais
entre qui on peut supposer de nouveaux
ray écailles lorraine mais pourquoi
paquet lorraine et luke skywalker
sachant que cai lorraine aura terminé
son entraînement carcenac a précisé
qu'il terminerait l'entraînement de
celui ci à la fin du set
j'aimerais beaucoup un combat entre
stocker luc ce serait le combat le plus
épique et permettrait enfin snoeck de se
dévoiler réellement car nous connaîtrons
forcément aussi l'identité de celui-ci
au bout d'un moment
enfin une nouvelle base sera
certainement construite comme l'étoile
de la mort
que pensez vous de tout ça
ces deux personnages sont les piliers de
cette nouvelle saga
d'un côté nous avons aurait futur jedi
et anciennement pilleurs d'épaves et
kyle aux reines chevaliers de rennes et
adepte du côté obscur apprentis de snow
que cependant ces deux personnages sont
très mystérieux et nous en savons encore
trop peu sur eux parlons de ré pour
commencer ray subi de nombreux chocs
émotionnels depuis le début de star wars
est lé limite considérée comme une élue
nous serons très probablement l'identité
de ses parents et toute l'histoire
autour de ré mais rappelez-vous dans
star wars est restée pris de peur face à
ses responsabilités et à son passé face
hamas qu'est ce qui pourrait se passer
quand elle apprendra tout sur son passé
et ses parents et si ray basculer du
côté obscur
ce serait vraiment très intéressant et
cela changerait des star wars habituel
ray pourrait basculer du côté obscur et
pourquoi pas suite à l'entraînement de
l'udc qui avait déjà subi les
retournements de veste de kayes lorraine
ce serait vraiment un coup dur entre
n'est pas encore tout à fait vrai même
si elle passe un peu pour la fille
gentille et solitaire mais perdu dans
son passé on en sait encore trop peu la
force est très puissante en elle elle
pourrait très bien vouloir acquérir plus
de puissance mais j'ai une autre version
lors de sa rencontre avec luke skywalker
qui nous dit que l'udc n'aurait pas tout
simplement tuer ses parents et ré
désemparé basculerait du côté obscure
car elle veut protéger ses nouveaux amis
comme anakin auparavant ray est
considérée comme la nouvelle élue par
beaucoup de fans
il se pourrait qu'elles suivent le
mauvais chemin khanaqinne emprunter
c'est un réel mystère mais pas vraiment
si anodin enfin parlons de calais
lorraine maintenant il veut jouer aux
grands sites mais il ne l'est pas il
voit même encore le côté lumineux
on le voit dans le film devant le casque
de vador
il a même tué son père pour prouver
qu'il était un vrai adeptes du côté
obscur mais portant on doute encore sur
le personnage de kayes lorraine tout
comme la mort de l'udc je suis sûr à
100% que kay lorraine redeviendra bon
déjà par le fait qu'il voit encore le
côté lumineux
aucun site à part vador n'a revu le côté
lumineux donc ça prouve déjà quelque
chose
ensuite la mort de son père l'a déchiré
et j'aurais sur la vie qu'il l'a tuée
vraiment pour fuir son retour vers le
côté lumineux car il sait que ses
parents en sont capables on le voit
jusqu'à pleurer de souffrance face à ce
dilemme
cai lorraine est encore très jeune et
très douteux je pense sincèrement qu'il
tournera sa veste et reviendra du bon
côté de la force aux côtés de sa mère
les ya peut-être y aura-t-il ce nom qui
serait en train de tuer ray avec les
éclairs de la force comme dark vador
avec sidious qui sait n'hésitez pas
interagir c'est important pour moi
vous m'avez beaucoup demandé de faire
des théories sur star wars 8 et j'ai
pris beaucoup de plaisir à le faire que
le lay en force soit avec vous cet argot
rock